growth hacking is a major buzzword in
the marketing industry right now it's
all about growing your business quickly
last lesson we spoke about a few
examples
do things that don't scale in the
beginning you may want to pass out
postcards or door hangers but that's not
something you're going to want to do
when you have a million users
referral bonuses have helped many
companies achieve success
paypal gave 10 bucks to new customers
and 10 bucks to the people who referred
them
suggesting followers or people who share
the app with is another way to gain
users with twitter they suggested people
to follow their members because they
knew that if people were following and
being followed they were more likely to
be active
but let's take a moment to explore a few
more take youtube for example when they
were first starting out they utilize
giveaways and contests to attract new
users to create accounts and upload
videos they're giving away an ipod nano
a day remember those as we talked about
previously in the course they also use
partnerships to help accelerate their
business like the one that they did with
myspace now uber on the other hand did
some in-person growth hacking
they teamed up with google ventures and
drove around entrepreneurs and investors
for free giving entrepreneurs 15 minutes
to pitch investors an idea during the
ride this was a great way to get future
influencers talking about their service
and caring about it now imagine if mark
zuckerberg in every interview he did
told people that he got his start in the
back seat of his uber rather than in a
dorm room
uber also teamed up with a northern
california blow dry bar where you get
your hair shampooed and blow dry
they offered free rides to all of their
clients that booked a blowout this
allowed them to one get press and two
access another niche market and finally
foursquare lets you leverage other
platforms for example you can post
check-ins to your facebook timeline for
other potential users to see
because growth hacking is so popular
these days we can't cover everything in
this course however we've posted links
to articles if you're interested in
learning more and reading more examples
of growth hacking
thinking about a small brand or a small
startup it's really important to embrace
grassroots tactics think constant
engagement think things like giveaways
and contests anything that can move the
needle in the right direction and help
build your social media follower base
it's also important to consider things
like user generated content getting
great content from your users quotes
anything tactical like that can really
pay off and help engage with your
customer base